I think her greatest relevance and
strength is as people discover
themselves and they say wow I am
entitled to my own life self-interest is
good hi I'm Nicolas booth reason TV
today we're talking with John Aguilar oh
he is the producer the man the author
behind the Atlas Shrugged trilogy the
third installment of which comes out on
September 12th 2014 to everyone within
the range of my voice this is John Galt
speaking those who have left you are
eager to build a world of freedom
John thanks for talking to reason
absolutely how does it feel to have
brought the Atlas Shrugged trilogy to
completion this you bought the rights to
this in 1992 and you're almost done with
it it's inspirational it's something
that I know that Iran would have wanted
to do
she tried with a number of people
including herself right she left a
partly finished script wrote that part
of a script part of a play but in the
end she wasn't she did not want to give
up creative control room that really was
the thing that prevented the move from
being made there were a couple of
producers out ruudy who produced The
Godfather one in particular they
actually had a news conference back in
72 I believe they announced are going to
make the movie and all of that but the
creative control was was a tough one for
her so you were lucky enough then to buy
the rights after she had expired was
August of 1992 I went to Hollywood to
some of the you know God got it some of
the studio Chiefs and talked to them and
some were explicitly said can't happen
we won't we won't get box office was it
based on the idea that the move the book
was unfilmable that if the creative
control issue was going to be a problem
or or is it that they didn't like the
message because you always fear about it
you know Angelina Jolie or Oliver Stone
or any number of liberal Hollywood types
you know who love ein Rand and talked
about this book is huge so what what was
their hesitation oh yeah I think she had
two opponents mm-hmm one one from the
left so the left does not like endorse
free markets limited government those
words scare the left politically so they
were in charge of making a movie and
didn't and felt a hesitancy to want to
do that now they felt it would be a
box-office success they're not idiots
they would have done it the other side
was from I think the the right from from
the religious side of
right right after the book was published
in 1957 Yoshi got a lot of pushback on
the fact that she was an atheist so tell
me though how does it feel you know so
you you finished the three movies the
first two have not been reviewed well I
mean they've been critically kind of
admonished box office has been pretty
good by your reckoning no no no it was
it was trashed as you said and and box
office has been low what has been
interestingly high has been the DVD
sales and the rental the after a box
office sales and part of that suffered
because you know in Hollywood you put up
a movie you put up a hundred million or
more a big part of your budget 2030
million or more is is advertised mm-hmm
and we had limited funds for that talk
about the relevance because I mean
you're you're right that you know this
this is the type of project that has a
huge afterlife and it's kind of
inspirational in the sense of you know
people who read I'm Rand and people who
read Atlas Shrugged in particular it's
one of those books that a lot of people
describe it as life-changing you know it
just blows people's minds what's the
relevance of Rand to contemporary
America and you know and to the people
who are renting and buying the Atlas
Shrugged movies I think our greatest
relevance and strength is is people
discover themselves and in an intrinsic
an explicit way and they say wow I am
entitled to my own life self-interest is
good and I think that's been the most
overwhelming aspect of your question so
that I mean it's it's interesting that
you put it in that sense because I'm
Rand is usually talked about as the
goddess of the market or whatever but
what you're talking about is something
that is you know it can be expressed in
kind of economic terms but it's actually
much more basic and fundamental and the
Declaration of Independence
said Thomas Jefferson life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness and yet we're
taught at schools universities were
taught and churches that self-interest
is a vice selfishness is a vice what is
wrong with the caricature and you see
this both on the the religious right as
well as on the progressive left people
saying well you know what I Rand is
really all about is his self-interest is
selfishness it's about egoism it's about
me me me I think I and ran made a
mistake she stuck with the vernacular of
the word selfishness so rather than
spending all the time that she did and
her her team her collective as they run
ironically called them on saying
enlightened self-interest saying ethical
self-interest
you know qualifying in some way but to
stay with that word selfishness it's in
the vernacular as negative you are you
know you're a hardcore libertarian do
you consider yourself an Objectivist as
well yes I would say I am an Objectivist
slash libertarian so you have a
political philosophy or a personal and
political philosophy that is all about
freedom and individual rights how do you
take your philosophy which is before
politics and then how do you choose how
to express it in politics well I I
express it as a libertarian first of all
it's easier to do the libertarian
movement libertarian thought there's no
longer fringe it's it's out there and it
expresses itself to one of two parties
generally Republicans so I will
generally vote Republican so and you
don't see any issue or you don't see any
hope for the Democrats to become more
free trade more less a fair in terms of
economics I've got a friend over 50
years
the between 50 and 60 60 years he is a
ultra left-liberal
he'll come back to me and say in essence
markets are messy they're untidy and too
many people are gonna slip through the
the safety net and that's why I don't
like your market capitalism thing no and
so the other side as much as they cause
angst with us entrepreneur market types
they have a position that they believe
in I think it's incorrect but they're
Americans they love George Washington
like I do and they're just wrong about
our economics well let's talk about
economics and and your business history
you started out selling snow cones and
then when did you first realize that you
had both an interest in being in a
talent for being an entrepreneur and for
being a business man yeah it was very
young I mean why like so many
entrepreneurs we cut lawns I would pick
blackberries in a an old farm area and
got permission to go through there and I
would get pints and do them or those it
was was a great feeling to put out
effort work and then be able to buy my
own ice cream cone or you know take my
girlfriend out to the movies get some
popcorn I like that I like the control
of that and so it yeah I went in my old
hometown colleagues with New Jersey I
would get on the bus take a few miles
trip to a nice station get crushed ice
50-pound bag put it on my back put it in
the bus take it back put it on the wagon
get some flavors and in front of the
mayor's office of colleagues in New
Jersey allowed me Main Street and I sold
snow cones that was beginning of it and
so what what is the essence of an oh
yeah and I've been I've thought about
the Elliott I I think I think an
entrepreneur
they have a gift for knowing what's
around the corner they're risk-adverse
people have to get to the corner peer
around take a look you know double-check
triple-check and then they know what
direction to go entrepreneur just have
an uncanny ability to take data and a
sense of history or pieces of current
date ends and make a guess they're often
wrong but they're generally are right
and they're paid well for whatever
product or service they put in the
market that people voluntarily want to
buy and that makes them good honest
charitable moral people in spite of the
crap that people say about them they're
essentially great human beings
entrepreneurs talk about cronyism and
crony capitalism because that's a huge
you know in Atlas Shrugged it's not
necessarily the you know poor people who
are on welfare they're not the villains
it's actually the incredibly
well-connected businessmen and the
politicians who want to play ball with
each other it's probably almost
impossible to get rid of cronyism
there's the government itself has large
contracts there's bridges to be built
buildings military to support with
services and supplies all of this is
going on and each of these companies
prolonged industries that hire lobbyists
to get the laws and bidding contracts
done in just the same way and just the
way they would like so it's easy and
proper to shoot cronyism I'm not saying
you won't that's not going to happen but
if but the size of government is is is
going to create an environment where
it'll be impossible to get rid of it
what we need to do I think just to
follow up is I think we need a simple
tax
I'm not saying a flat tax I think a flat
tax is a again it's a
a lot of people don't view that as the
answer but I think you to get to the
mountaintop you got to take you got to
get halfway there first so when you say
a simple text what what do you mean I
mean we'll probably be rather we're not
gonna get a postcard but I think we can
get three four pages tax code rather
than a hundred thousand page tax code by
having some level of progressivity so if
you make a million dollars a year you're
gonna pay 400 thousand forty percent if
you make fifty thousand a year you're
gonna pay eight percent mm-hmm so
progressivity no you can't again you got
to get halfway there to the mountains so
that gets I mean that would clarify that
would that would get rid of a lot of
incentives that the government can build
into sweetheart deals that the
government can build exactly how do you
restrain spending that the dollar that
the government gets for every dollar of
tax what does it get probably 60 cents
more to house the other forty percent go
but we don't need the amount of
regulation I mean let's at least pick up
the low-hanging fruit first let's go for
that first yeah but I think if we do
that that will get rid of a lot of the
cronyism mm-hmm
by having those having having the tax
revenues jump because you're taking the
cost out of collecting money by the
government you also run executive health
exams or ehe a lot of your your
businesses are interested in this kind
of quality of life and particularly
physical life do you think the
interesting kind of life extension or
you know kind of I mean this is true
self ownership of you know it's your
body you you know you better take care
of it every bit as much as you take care
of your car or your house does that fit
in with a kind of Randy and enlightened
self-interest I've never thought of it
in that way but I think you're right
it's a very good observation that we
take care of our minds she says through
our ability to have independence to
choose responsibly the direction we want
to go in life and our mental sense of
life helps
that but to do that you've got to carry
on a healthy life and I mean it started
out it would give people exams and kind
of help them figure out what was you
know what they needed to work on in
order to yeah I think the instincts were
very good at the time because the the
capital the people put up that not the
doctors but the people put the capital
were insurance companies and banks and
the insurance companies in their own
room and Terry way we're saying you can
pay less insurance if you get if we can
check you out
we get physical exam and that that idea
has has value and it took off and it's
as valuable today as it was then and in
many ways more so right because we can
actually change I mean you could if you
can identify a particular problem you're
much more likely to be able to fix it
right and not just by having expensive
operations or expensive drugs we know
that celiac disease can be beaten by
abstinence don't eat we laid in bread
talked about the role of William Howard
Taft in the Life Extension Institute
well William Howard Taft President Taft
was the worst example one could have as
their poster child for life extension
this Institute at the time though he
lived a pretty long time yeah he did he
did he did we wrote a book about at the
75th anniversary of we also just wrote a
hundredth anniversary my beloved wife
Joan Carter wrote that book she also
wrote a book called the the making of
Atlas Shrugged trilogy but she wrote a
book on how helped assist with a hundred
but we wrote a 75th anniversary book and
President Taft is there he helped form
this company and I think he also helped
form a sense a job a judgment that
checking out your body periodically is a
good thing and so with that basic idea
he has the first chairman of the board
of trustees we were founded well let's
end with a kind of a discussion of the
future I mean in a way libertarians
broadly speaking a lot of people who are
a fan
vine random always talk about the
current moment as the absolute worst
possible moment to be alive you know
government has never been so big and so
intrusive things have never been so
awful you mentioned that Rand is really
about optimism and that that optimism
that she had about creating a life that
you want to live gets beaten out of them
beaten out of kids they forget the
optimism of when life was ahead of them
you've just completed a major major
product you know project a life's
project with the Atlas Shrugged trilogy
do you still have optimism what's still
ahead of you
I'm absolutely optimistic I think about
what we've done in the last hundred
years 300 years 500 years that the wards
and the monarchies and the churches in
the battle and look at today with the
extremism but we'll be here in a century
or five centuries or the next millennia
millennium and the living will be a lot
better than it is now okay well thank
you very much we'll leave it there I
want to thank John Aguilar oh he is the
man behind the Atlas Shrugged trilogies
also the chairman of Cybex and executive
health exams John thanks for talking to
Reason TV enjoy it for reason TV I'm
Nikolas me